this meeting ended with a strong
condemnation of Russia for its
continuing war in Ukraine reaffirming
the g7's commitment to sanctions and
stopping Moscow getting weapons from
third countries with the G7 Nations
accounting for much of the heavy
Weaponry now being prepared for the
long-anticipated counter-offensive
against Russian forces this was a
message of unity now as Ukraine prepares
to launch a counter-offensive to take
back its land to liberate its people and
occupied territories to stop the
missiles bombs and drones which continue
to rain down on its civilians we stand
with Ukraine the foreign ministers also
called for greater action to counter the
growing influence and power of China in
the indo-pacific with a strong message
of support for Taiwan which China sees
as a breakaway territory and that it's
threatened to take by force if necessary
as the only Asian G7 Nation the host
Japan fears if Russia can act with
impunity in Europe China can do the same
here
the security of Europe and the security
of the indo-pacific are inseparable and
I have a sense that Ukraine's crisis
could be East Asia's tomorrow
and has also been promoting nuclear
disarmament at this meeting hoping to
advance its non-proliferation goals when
it hosts G7 leaders at their Summit in
Hiroshima next month the location of the
world's first atomic attack it may seem
fanciful at a time of growing
International crises even to expect
Nations to consider disarmament but
according to the Japanese hosts it is
precisely because of the escalating
conflicts that the existence of large
Nuclear stockpiles So imperils the world
and there's never been a more important
time to give up those weapons Rob
McBride Al Jazeera Caro wizawa Japan